I remember the first time when I stepped on the pedal
I love how quiet it is
I love how seamless it is
How it pulls off from zero, and that speed and that power and that torque
The favourite features that I continue to love about Tesla is the software updates
It is the feeling that your car is always new
I felt so safe inside
Everything was set-up and everything was so easy
I personally really like using the app thats how I could always check when I should charge the car
Driving in Hong Kong is pretty hectic
There’re a lot of cars coming in and out
I think it is so hard in Hong Kong to find a peace of mind
No matter if you re on a bus or even in a car with an engine
And with a Tesla, it makes so much easier especially with the Autopilot on the highways
It is almost like to me swimming
You find the peace and then you can hear that inner voice of yours
You will always remember it
You will always remember that feeling